[Music]
look I think change is scary I think
there is no way around that I think what
is familiar is is easier for people and
and not everybody wants disruption and
innovation and entrepreneurship not
everybody wants to have seven jobs that
sounds terrible to a lot of people I
think the idea the sort of assumption
that everybody is an entrepreneur is a
bit of a mistake I think many people are
willing to be entrepreneurs with giving
no other option but a lot of those
people would rather just have a job like
not everybody is a founder that's okay
this is not some failure right like
founders are sort of unique animals
right in sort of our social system
social ecosystem but what I think it
requires of us as individuals is this
pace of change is unlikely to be slowed
down in a way that is productive right
it could be slowed down in ways that are
super unproductive like being
isolationist and protectionist and
trying to make a global economy smaller
in ways that will ultimately hurt more
people than it will help I think there
are ways of slowing down innovation but
I don't think any of them are actually
good for people I think the reality is
we have to get better at teaching
flexibility we have to teach critical
thinking and adaptability to students as
part of how we're preparing people for
the future we also have to be willing
this is where leadership matters a lot
willing to be more ambitious for
ourselves we tend to think about
progress in generational terms I want my
kids to be better off than I am well why
wait for your kids like why not if it's
if it's easier and more effective to
make something somewhere else and we can
take on a bigger problem and I believe
that the we can do that that we have the
capacity to embrace something more
ambitious for ourselves now in our
lifetime in a way that isn't terrifying
in an evident way that isn't it's is
about seeing these things as
opportunities and addressing the anxiety
of trying trying new things and
embracing new things and that requires
leadership that's confidence inspiring
and that speaks to the discomfort that
we're in and that meets us at an
emotional level of leadership that I
think politicians are pretty scared of a
lot of the time and I don't think it's
just politicians I think it's also
business leaders I think it's community
leaders I think this is a cultural shift
in an attitude toward what success looks
like and what work looks like and it may
be the case that you know we've moved
we're moving into this sort of
post-industrial economy we're sort of in
this complicated shifts right and there
industrial jobs are moving and changing
and you know value is no longer linearly
correlated with work right so if in a
perfect and typical industrial system if
I work more hours I create more value in
a relatively linear equation right which
is why an hourly wage makes sense but in
a world where one more hour of work
might create 10x more value but in the
world we're currently and all of that
value goes to an investor and none of it
goes to me as the worker hourly wages
make no sense and it might be the case
that if we did a better job sharing in
that value creation and spreading the
cost of disruption around more
effectively maybe we only need to work
30 hours a week and maybe that is full
employment right maybe our definition of
full employment is needs to be revisited
just like a lot of our other assumptions
and maybe we don't need seven jobs maybe
we just need to do a better job sharing
the value we're creating and that leaves
more time to be parents like I don't
know that we need to take as a given the
40-hour workweek most other countries
don't have I think look I think this
concept of shared success and collective
progress leads us toward a conversation
that invites the question of universal
basic income I'm I think it's a really
interesting idea I I'm not an expert in
it and I'm not convinced that it's the
only answer I think things like
wiring companies to do things like
profit sharing is part of the same
conversation right that ultimately what
universal basic income is about is that
we are collectively creating value and
we should collectively share in that
value I believe in that a hundred
percent I think that that we live in a
community where accepting the suffering
of any of us makes all of us poorer and
makes all of us less well-off right and
accepting that that is like the default
part of the gradient should be
unacceptable to us is the answer
government like a minimum a gut check
from a government that creates a minimum
layer maybe that may be exactly the kind
of public good that the government
should create the question is who gets
it and how and when and what are the
cut-offs and I think which is not to say
it's a bad idea I just think it's a lot
more complicated at the point of
implementation and most people talk
about of who qualifies what if I make
enough money I mean this is a similar
conversation to welfare who qualifies at
what point does you know am I making
enough money that I don't qualify for
that and does that create a valley or a
cliff in my economic well-being in
progress that creates problems for
people that people get stuck in this
valley right which is very true with
especially welfare where you must be
working to get to benefit from welfare
the work first mentality that started in
the eighties means that you can't like
for instance study while and welfare
because you have to work full-time and
so you can study at night and I know yes
you can go to go to work and you can
study at the same time but it creates
incentives that create this weird valley
in the middle of sort of the way welfare
systems get through the our welfare
system gets executed United States I
think that's the kind of thing we have
to be really really conscious and
careful of with Universal is going to go
I think the concept that anybody that we
should accept that anybody anybody
living in poverty shouldn't be
acceptable to us there we have we have
enough wealth and value and upwards
in this country for that not to be true
and I think accepting it as true is just
us wimping out on a hard problem
[Music]